welcome to this five-minute game mara
Angus comic book comedian okay so okay
going with the b6 line the English
Defence not the most reliable of
openings but played it sometimes that's
a good line unfortunately let's see
we're just doing this jump to you for
know is going to three
maybe I can do this then play for d5
just some some normal moves d5 he might
have a five but ok let's I want to play
in the center here not do something
weird 597 doesn't maybe I mean it is he
has also made surprising a 54 and if you
cannot go if I've what is this move I
can actually play Bishop g2 take sand
castles because of my unprotected bishop
on b7 that's maybe the IDM
hmm so I take it yeah I probably want to
take my mind my development is not
exactly great but he has to spend wow I
thought you would just okay j-just
castle and here maybe knight c6 and then
castling long ideas Nigeria which is
duly ignored
yeah maybe maybe for some reason okay
yeah I wanted to do this anyway hmm yeah
I thought 94 might be an idea yeah yeah
let's push that deep on can go d 31 like
okay let's play play it simple this
position is probably just equal all
right hmm i don't like a I can talk
these three maybe d 3 and then Bishop
Jake's be too was that possible I mean
okay it's definitely possible but is it
any good yeah maybe check
ok so here and then idea was to go to d6
then to c5 check and try to do something
with the pair of bishops I can I could
always take on d5 44 draw basically I
wanted to try for more ok I 5b should be
five wins upon two pounds even
so yeah is he really going to go a five
maybe I can go Bishop c5 then though
this pieces are somewhat shaky capturing
I didn't think about that move but for
not even for a single moment okay and so
we should see five
mm yeah okay it looks vecchie but is it
bad mmm Bishop f4 maybe yeah that's
sorry that's simple but probably not bad
angling for this for this w NJ and now
rook a5 threatens rook e8 and grab or
the f5 porn okay he can maybe and do
that can maybe swing look G 1 over I can
go rookie a dumpy seven though okay it's
not i will be success idea okay so maybe
this move that just attack the pawn
looks difficult for for white losing
quite some horns him check check three
pawns is a lot I can keep them for the
chat time being check so I'm covering
every my morning can push porn Snow
White resigns yeah so what failed okay i
was a bit i was really surprised the way
he played that was he takes I mean he
takes that didn't occur to me I was
expecting to go if I here in this
position I am sorry and if I he is not
possible at all i can just take him and
I mean maybe this yeah I didn't expect
that but yeah here this is weird why
doesn't he wasn't he castle in here I
cannot take it anyway because of that
unprotected bisha right here after
Bishop e7 we can quite conveniently take
on e4 and now castling is so is already
done for white tournament here I really
should be ok Nigerian by the bike by
stockfish but that's not bad either
check check ok maybe not the the best
possible line but no
bad line yeah he worshiped e5 is already
leading to dead equality because I
wanted to try something here check this
is this and now he went a form and a4a
for son I think he should do something
to address this f5 IDM and I think after
a five-year I've after a five black has
a very big advantage hey sis he's
falling apart a little bit rocky one is
the the starfish move intending to take
with the king it's not very human check
check can you [ __ ] t4 check check and
why it's supposed to be just slightly
worse yeah maybe very difficult to play
and here we should be seven was already
better I has no way to cover that I just
wind that piece I didn't think about
Bishop e7 check
now I briefly thought about this after
which this is really possible hmm yeah
what very good candidate moves here I
say we I just saw Bishop f4 and I said
okay this is just really nice for me so
why not go for that the engine however
is merciless and points out that Gucci
one should draw I intended this and
rookie seven but now this is going to be
a draw according to the computer check
yeah that seems very likely the f pawns
are very dangerous so check I probably
have to give that perpetual him know
that was the opportunity for white and
after this it's probably going to be
lost in five him here here it's a loss
yeah there was a decent game I should
have played Bishop e7 though that would
have made the whole thing much much
easier to play okay well thanks for
watching